je reviens de venise où j'ai participé à
la biennale internationale des métiers
d'art homo faber
c'est un grand rendez-vous pour
l'artisanat d'art il ya les plus grands
maîtres artisans du monde et plus de 30
pays sont représentés
et vous savez avec qui j'ai été là-bas
avec anna karina ragga c'est une
bijoutière vénézuélienne arrivé en
france en tant que réfugié en 2016
vous demandez peut-être
comment cette artisane parlant à peine
le français à son arrivée en france
ayant perdu tout ce qu'elle avait at
elle pu participer au plus grand
rendez-vous d'artisanat d'art
et bien au démarrage de cette histoire
incroyable
c'est l'histoire d'une autre artisanes
celle de ma propre mère
je voulais toujours connu mère au foyer
des voix l'éducation de ses six enfants
c'est à 35 ans que je découvre qu'elle
est et brodeuses en tunisie un métier qu
à l'abandonner à son arrivée en france
j'ai été avec ses broderies magnifique
entre mes mains et je me suis demandé
mais pourquoi at elle abandonné son
savoir faire
comme ma mère
anna karina a failli renoncer aux siens
un jour un artisan c'est rien ne disait
j'ai tout perdu mon pays ma langue ma
famille
mais la seule chose que j'ai réussi à
emporter avec moi si le savoir-faire que
j'ai entre mes mains
c'est pour cette raison que j'ai fondé
la fabrique nomades
nous avons accompagné efforts mais anna
karina pendant neuf mois elle a suivi
des cours de français
découvert son secteur professionnel
grâce à des visites d'ateliers des
visites de salons et rencontrer d'autres
artisans il ya là collaborait avec une
designer pour créer une collection de
bijoux qui à la fois va valoriser son
savoir faire lui aussi démontré son
adaptation au marché français
anna karina est aujourd'hui
créatrice de bijoux elle est
indépendante et tout récemment elle a
collaboré sur un magnifique projet avec
le groupe lvmh
elle a travaillé avec l'artiste gérer ni
gober
et quatre autres artisanes réfugiés
ensemble ils ont créé une oeuvre qui
s'appelle conversation etc si tu
c'est justement cette oeuvre qui a été
présenté à venise
là bas un à karina a fait des
démonstrations de savoir faire et le
public a été stupéfait par sa technique
et l'alchimie des couleurs qu'elle
arrivait à créer
c'était incroyable de l'avoir avec tant
de fierté de confiance sur cette scène
internationale
on peut dire qu'un hack arena a trouvé
sa place en tant qu'artisan
j'ai aussi envie de vous parler d'un
couturier brodeur sénégal est talentueux
il s'appelle à blaye marc
il maîtrise la technique de broderie la
cornée me c'est un savoir faire français
mais que peu de personnes maîtrisant
france
depuis son enfance à blaye n'a qu'un
rêve créer sa propre maison de haute
couture
comme beaucoup de migrants il a traversé
l'italie où il a fait beaucoup de petits
boulots et à son arrivée à paris il a
déposé son cv dans plusieurs agences
d'intérim mais il n'a jamais été rappelé
il a installé sa machine corner ni dans
un petit atelier qui partageait avec
d'autres couturiers africains à la
goutte d'or dans le xviiie à paris
après sa formation à la fabrique nomades
il décroche un entretien dans un atelier
de couture parisiens
je décide de l'accompagner
on arrive tous les deux on se présente à
l'accueil et une femme des boules des
escaliers il ya elle se dirige tout
droit vers à blaye il ya lui dit d'un
ton agacé c'est vous le coursier pour la
maison dior
vous ressentez le malaise
moi je me suis dit qu est fait sur place
cette simple question était une vraie
claque de préjugés
bla et lui il s'est arrêté à ça il a été
recruté et il a été tellement brillant
que la directrice de l'atelier la
recommander à des agences d'intérim
et c'est là que commence son parcours
qui lui ce à la maison kenzo où il
exerce son métier depuis quatre ans
maintenant
derrière cette réussite c'est une fierté
et une identité retrouvée grâce à son
métier qui lui permet non seulement de
devenir un acteur à part entière de la
société
mais in fine et de se sentir enfin chez
lui
d'ailleurs en 2019 il obtient la
nationalité française
à blaye est aujourd'hui un artisan
français fier de ces deux cultures et de
son savoir faire il joue un rôle modèle
pour nos artisans car il porte un
message d'espoir
je suis convaincu câble à écrire un jour
sa maison de haute couture qui fera
peut-être la renommée de la france comme
kenzo ce créateur japonais
- son parcours je trouve incroyable car
elle bouscule tellement d'idées reçues
derrière l'étiquette de réfugiés se
cachent bien souvent des talents
insoupçonnés
maintenant
ensemble nous allons faire un reset
vous pouvez fermer les yeux
quand je vous dis réfugiés migrants
quelles sont les premières images qui
vous viennent immédiatement à l'esprit
comme moi vous voyez des bateaux en
déroute sur la méditerranée des
campements de fortune une masse de
personnes en différencier
la misère l'insécurité
maintenant je vous demande de remplacer
ces images par l'histoire d'anna karina
il à blaye
vous voyez des gestes
des savoir-faire la création
l'excellence le courage et la résilience
pour ouvrir les yeux
maintenant je vous invite à agir car
nous sommes tous des acteurs de
changement sommeil qui ne demande qu'à
être éveillé
tout à l'heure en quittant cette
magnifique salle vous discuterez avec le
chauffeur de taxi qui vont raccompagnera
chez vous demain au travail vous
croiserez la femme de ménage ou encore
le coursier qui vous livre à votre
compte votre commande
si cette personne est étrangère
demandez-lui quel métier faisait vous
dans votre pays avant d'arriver en
france
et là deux possibilités la première île
où elle était artisan et là sans aucune
hésitation
contactez moi
contactée la fabrique naumann car ce
sont peut-être des mains en or qui
mérite d'être révélée la deuxième
possibilité
il était technicien elle était
professeur infirmières médecins
architectes commerçants vraiment vous
n'avez pas aidé des compétences qui
arrivent en france vous seriez surpris
il sans doute choquée de voir le
décalage qu'il ya entre le métier qu'ils
exerçaient dans leur pays le métier
qu'ils font en france
il ya cette personne vous allez lui dire
la france a besoin de ton talent et de
tes compétences
et en disant ça vous allait semer en
elle une graine d'espoir qui va tout
simplement
l'autorisé à être
parfois il suffit de pas grand chose
pour changer la vie d'une personne
d'une rencontre d'un déclic d'une
étincelle comme l'a été l'histoire de ma
mère qui a transformé mon indignation
en engagement
et cet engagement a permis à plus de 80
artisans
d'exister aujourd'hui est d'être reconnu
en france
et des artisans qui représente plus de
20 savoir faire différent
la fabrique nomades joue un rôle de
passerelle entre ces mondes
ce soir je suis devant vous et je
partage avec vous ses histoires qui
j'espère transformer durablement votre
regard
le monde a besoin de ce reset pour
permettre à d'autres de faire le restart
merci